JENNA TAYLOR: Hello.
Welcome, everyone, to
the teaching kitchen
at KitchenSync.
My name is Jenna Taylor.
I'm a food services manager
here in Mountain View,
and I want to thank you all
for joining us here today.
This teaching
kitchen is special.
It was the first of
its kind at Google.
Since it opened, we've built
another one in Pittsburgh.
We're planning for Seattle,
Kirkland, New York, hopefully
others.
The food program at Google
invests in these spaces
because food literacy
and engagement are really
at the heart of our mission,
which is ultimately to enable
Googlers to be at their best.
So yes, we provide
you with great food,
but it's also important
to us that we empower you
with the knowledge and
skills necessary to make
delicious, nutritious food at
home and in your communities,
because really we believe
that cooking together
builds community.
It enables collaboration,
and it gives you another way
to be creative and innovative.
The bonus is spaces
like this also
give us a place
to welcome experts
from the culinary industry.
So today we are very privileged
to have Zagat Guest Chef Scott
Daigre with us.
Join me in welcoming
him, please.
SCOTT DAIGRE:Thank you.
Thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: Scott has a
very diverse background.
He's a landscape
designer, a farmer,
an avid gardener
He's a chef, and now
author of "Tomatomania!"
which I'm sure you're all
as excited as I am about.
He started out, really,
with the seedling sale,
wildly popular in
southern California.
Same name, still run that today.
Only now, he's further
sharing his passion
by coming out with the
book, "Tomatomania!"
It's really supposed to be a fun
and beautiful guide to growing,
preparing, cooking
tomatoes, all things
summertime and
deliciousness, so I can't
wait to hear more about it.
SCOTT DAIGRE:Thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks again, everybody.
Yeah, I loved-- there's nothing
better than being in a room
with a bunch of tomato
maniacs, you know?
What can I tell you?
And it was nice to meet so
many of you out this morning,
out in the-- the Growglers
out there in the gardens.
It's an amazing thing to be able
to grow, to eat what you grow,
and then get inspired by
eating and grow more things,
and you know, there you are.
We did this.
We did this book to
inspire with easy things.
This is not a super
complicated situation.
It really isn't.
It's an easy thing
that hopefully you
can take cues from your garden.
You'll see we have a few riffs,
a few variations on what we're
going do.
And the recipe that
we're looking at today
is called New
Tomatoes Rockefeller.
I grew up in Louisiana, so
the first dish I ever remember
was oysters Rockefeller from
Antoine's in New Orleans.
Have you ever been?
Go.
Put it on your lists right now.
Enter it in your phones.
That was a very
key thing for me.
It was something I remember
from being this big,
and when we put these
together, I said,
geez, I really like that,
and it's my first memory.
What could we do with tomatoes?
So Jenn Garbee, my
co-author, and I,
put together a new
tomatoes Rockefeller,
and that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So I look forward
to showing you this.
We'll go through some steps.
Thanks ahead of time to the
wonderful staff and chefs
here who have taken good care
of me and made this easy to do.
And we'll give you the--
we'll give you the go around.
You know what it all
begins with, obviously.
Tomatoes, OK?
No two ways about that.
It begins with tomatoes,
but the thing about it
is, you know, as you
well know, probably, you
can get lots of different
kinds of tomatoes
that you might grown
in your garden,
or find it anywhere with the
nursery if you're growing it,
the grocery store, if
you're buying them.
So it depends.
The beginnings of this recipe
start with what tomatoes
we're going to use.
If you're using a big
fat tomato like this,
we're putting these in the oven.
And we're basically going to
roast them like a roasted bell
pepper, so if you've got a big,
soft, flat heirloom like this,
it's not going to
hold up so well.
You have to be
careful about that,
especially if it's overripe.
Overripe ones are just
going to be really flat when
you get them out of the
oven, because they're just
going to sink away.
And conversely, if
you buy something
at the store-- you're familiar
with this, that number,
aren't you?
You're familiar with that guy,
the round, kind of pellet size
hard thing that we find in
the stores most of the year,
unfortunately, and don't
grow in our own gardens,
but this is quite useful for us.
And we're going to do
a combination today,
because it works for
us in the kitchen,
and we'll talk
about that as we go.
The first thing
that you want to do
is you want to create the
boat that you're going
to put this whole item in.
Again, it could be a large
boat, it could be a small boat.
You could even do these with
cherries if you got really,
really, really, really
careful, but the first thing
that I've done here
with these is obviously
I'm going to scoop them out.
And what I get
when I find this--
the book tells you to scoop
these out and use the innards.
When you use this from
the grocery store,
and you get this
really hard core,
it's really not very good
for you, or good to you,
and it's really
hard to work with.
So I'm going to totally cheat
today, because, again, I
want to use something
that I bought at the store
for its firmness.
And I want to use some beautiful
heirloom tomatoes over here
for the actual-- for the
actual stuffing that we're
going to eat, or most of
the stuffing that we're
going to eat.
When you scrape out a
tomato, you obviously
are going to take
out all the seeds,
and you're going to take out as
much of the juice as you can.
You want to set these face down.
You can set them
anywhere, right?
Set them face down and let
them drain just a little bit,
so you get some of that
moisture out there.
And what you'll also have to
choose as you go through this
is where you cut this tomato,
where you cut it in half.
You can make them super flat
and small, so little, bitty
appetizer, you know,
like a smaller appetizer
kind of a thing.
Or just a little bitty taste,
or if you get these big ones,
you just take off
that top level.
And you've got quite
a hefty monster there
that you can fill with
all this good stuff
that we're going to add.
So again, you continue to do
as many as you want there.
The recipe that we're working
with in this book makes
8 to 10 servings,
which would be 8
to 10 finished halves, or
2/3, or whatever it is you
want to do.
After you drain those--
and I don't have time
to fully drain
them today-- we've
got the oven set at 400 degrees.
That's where you start.
Good, round number.
And I'm going to put these in
there for six to eight minutes.
Don't let me forget, OK?
Because that would be terrible.
But anyway, you're going
to put them in the oven,
and you're just going to let
those heat up just a little bit
and soften while we move
on to the next part of what
we're doing.
The dressing.
It begins here.
Do you know what fennel is?
Do you know fennel is?
Beautiful, frothy kind of a
plant, good bug attractant,
really good for you
gardeners out there,
if you want to get a
good, healthy garden.
We're going to start with
a teaspoon of fennel seed.
This is whole fennel
seed, all right?
And if you don't-- if you've
ever worked with-- well,
it's just like-- getting
ground fennel in a canister
or in a little glass bottle,
it's kind of like grabbing--
to me anyway-- grabbing the
tomato from the grocery store,
rather than out
of your backyard.
If you get a whole
fennel seed, you
had the advantage of
being able to crush it
and getting all those really
wonderful flavors immediately
escaping from the seed.
So you have an opportunity
to do a little more with it.
This is a hot-- they tell
me this thing is hot.
I don't really believe
that because there's
no fire involved, but they
tell me it's very hot.
So we're moving on that.
Now, I don't know
if you can smell it,
but I can already smell it.
And all we're doing is we're
going to shake this around
for a minute or two, and we're
going to toast these slightly.
And what you're doing
is you're coaxing
a little flavor out of there.
And then what we're-- can
you see that smoke coming out
of there?
Can you see it?
Watch it closely.
Watch closely.
I'm about to do a magic trick.
There it goes, and you
can see it start to toast.
And you really are just going
to do this for a couple minutes
at the most.
They won't change color.
They might darken just a little
bit, but what you are doing,
you're just creating something
kind of cool and different.
For those of you who
don't cook a lot,
this is kind of an easy
way to get a big wow,
and fennel, this
taste of fennel,
it's going to be very
pervasive in the dressing.
And it's what you want.
What we used here
was about a teaspoon.
If you're not a
fennel lover and you
want a little bit
of this taste, only
use half of that, because it
is a very pervasive, pervasive
taste.
All right, it's smoking.
These have darkened
a bit, and I'm
going to set those
out there to cool.
And we're going to move
on to to the rest of this.
How am I doing on those?
OK, two minutes in
on the tomatoes.
We're good to go, so
they're in the oven there.
They're just fine.
All right, we've got
our toasted fennel.
The next thing that I would do
normally-- and thank you, chef,
for taking good care
of me-- would be
to toast a little bit of bread.
Now, just like everything
else, the fresh tomato
and everything else,
good, fresh bread
is always going to get
you the best results.
So find some great, fresh bread.
If you don't have
that, day old bread
works as well, because
it's getting a little hard
and getting a little stiff,
and that's just fine.
You can use whatever you've got.
Slice it up, tiny, tiny pieces.
That's easier to work with.
Again, you're not working with
a football or a basketball here.
You're working
with a very-- oops.
You're working with a very
small little container.
Make them small.
This makes it more
variable or versatile
when you get back into the dish.
So all you need to do-- this is
what the chefs did here-- was
cube the bread, put
it on a flat tray,
pop it into the oven
for just five minutes,
and it firms up a
little bit more.
And you're ready to go.
You don't want it
to be really hard.
It's going to get covered with
sauce, with dressing-- sorry,
and you want it to get a
little-- you want it to soak up
a little bit of that,
so you don't want
it to be too terribly hard.
So that would've been step two.
Step three, moving
on to the dressing.
do you guys know what this is?
I love these things.
When you can pull these
out, this is really fun.
Kitchen fun at its best, right?
A mortar and pestle
is a really cool tool.
If you're lazy like
me, sometimes you'll
just get a fork,
and you know, make
the best of it, but
with this thing,
especially with these
cumin seeds-- oh, sorry,
the fennel seeds-- and what
you want to get out of it,
you want to use the
time-tested-- you
getting that there, Mike?
You want to use this
time-tested technique.
You want to smash it.
I don't know if
you can smell that.
Oh, my goodness, the smell
that comes out of there
when you-- maybe it'll
drift over to you.
But what you want to
do is you're basically
going to make dust.
You're making fennel dust
here, and that's what we want.
We want it to be really fine.
You don't need it to be--
you don't want any graininess
in there at all, OK?
And what you're going
to essentially do
to start this dressing
is you want a paste.
You want to make a
paste, and that's
what we're going to do with
the rest of these ingredients.
A clove of garlic, and
this one you can mash.
And since we're using
the mortar and pestle,
I don't even have to dice that.
I mean, I can, but what
you-- but you can really
use this sort of
like a caveman tool.
So it's kind of-- it's
not very new tech at all,
but it sure works to
get things ground up,
and that's a terrific way
to get this all finished.
All right, so I've
got garlic in there.
I've got my seed, and the
next thing is green onion.
And we took a medium bunch
of green onions, right?
Chopped them up really fine
into the mix, same thing.
And all this is just going
to-- get back in there.
It's going to mush
together, mush all together.
There's no fancy
way to say that.
It's going to mush.
Let me see what this is doing.
Oops, wrong oven.
All right, we're getting there.
Again, if you're using
a big, soft tomato,
you got to check that more
often, because of course it's
going to sink even-- it's
going to cook very, very fast.
So can you see that on the
monitor that's up there?
I don't know how close
you can see that.
It's not even really
attractive at this point.
But it does smell really
good, and that's what we want.
So again, it's the green
onion, it's the garlic,
and it's the fennel seed.
And you do that as
much as you need to do.
Now, every once in a while
in this mortar and pestle,
especially some of
these have little pits,
like these sort of rough ones.
Gather that up every
once in a while
and start over and see if
you can't get it all messed,
you know?
Get it all back into the mix.
Now, that's not
much of a dressing,
but we're going to add the good
stuff now to make it just so.
And I'd better pull
those babies out,
just so they don't go too far.
JENNA TAYLOR: Scott,
for those of us
who might not have a
caveman tool like this one,
is this something you could
do in a food processor?
A little--
SCOTT DAIGRE: You can, but then
you've got so much to clean.
What are you going to
do that for, you know?
JENNA TAYLOR: All those
parts and pieces to clean?
SCOTT DAIGRE: Yeah,
that's the thing.
Food processors, they
scare me, you know?
This is so easy.
Look at that.
JENNA TAYLOR: But if you want
to go a little more high tech.
SCOTT DAIGRE:Yes,
you could definitely,
but if you're going to do that--
JENNA TAYLOR: Fear
not, Googlers.
SCOTT DAIGRE: --if you're going
to do it, up your ingredients.
Like, up your
amounts just a little
bit because you'll lose it.
JENNA TAYLOR: To
really get traction?
SCOTT DAIGRE:Yeah,
you'll lose it.
Exactly.
You'll double it or
something, and then
split it before you
put it into the recipe.
And of course, this is easy.
If you're making this dressing,
it's kind of wonderful.
So I generally make
a lot of it, and then
use only what you need
for this particular one,
and save it for the rest
of the whatever, a week,
as long as whatever you got.
And I think it'll be great.
See how these have
lightened just a little bit?
You can see what's happened.
They're warm to the touch.
In fact, they're pretty soft.
And that's exactly
what you want.
They can cool or not.
It doesn't matter when
you do this next step.
It's going to be just fine.
So to this beautiful
mixture that I've now
put in the-- see how much you
lose on those blades of that
processsor?
See that?
You lose so much.
This is so much easier,
but anyway, we're
going to get the liquid portion.
Olive oil, obviously part of
every good salad dressing,
so the olive oil goes in there.
We've used about 3/4 of
a-- or 2 tablespoons,
excuse me, and Worcestershire
sauce, Worcestershire sauce,
right?
Right, chef?
Easy for you to say.
Just a tablespoon in there.
That's going to give us--
that makes our dressing.
Obviously this is what's
going to make it liquidy
enough to put into our salad.
Now it's still pretty pasty,
and that's what you want.
This is the point at which--
and here you go, how could that
possibly be enough, right?
Because it looks
pretty small in there.
That's OK.
Don't worry about it.
Just stick to those ingredients,
or to whatever ratio you've
developed, and
you'll be just fine.
So yeah, it's even
less attractive now,
but it's going ot taste
really, really good.
So it's all in there,
and we're ready to go.
And now, we get ready
to ready our arugula.
We've used arugula in
the base of this salad.
This is approximately
4 cups, and all
I'm going to do
to this puppy dog
is just lightly-- let me
use a little bit more.
All I'm going to
do here is lightly,
lightly chop, because again,
we're going into a small space,
and some of these arugula can
be as wide as that tomato is,
you know, wide, or more,
so all you're going to do
is you're going to chop
it just a bit, rough
chop so that it will
go, it'll fit better
into that whole situation.
All right?
Now, got spinach in the garden?
Use spinach.
It works wonderfully in this.
Got a favorite kale?
You could even do that.
So again, you know, rules
are rules, but they're also--
they're pretty much
made to be broken.
So if you've got
it, use it, and this
is a recipe that can
be really, really
versatile for other
things in your garden.
All right, light chop,
we're good to go,
and we're going to put
the arugula right there
into a beautiful bowl.
Now, we're going to go
backwards a little bit,
and we're going to
grab the bread, right?
The cubes that we got?
I'm going to put in
about half of this.
Some people don't like bread
in their salads at all.
Some people love it.
Make it work for you.
Croutons are croutons.
I like them, so we can
put a lot in there.
I'm going to add a
little bit of pepper,
and I'm going to add a
little touch of salt.
And I'm actually going to put
a little salt in the dressing
too, since I want that to
be sharp enough, right?
And then the last, we
had two more ingredients
to put in here.
The last is-- this is
a crumbly goat cheese.
Works perfectly.
Feta works as well.
We've used that before.
The other day I
made this for family
with a great Humboldt, a
great cowgirl creamy Humboldt,
and it was amazing.
Just be sure to chop it small.
You don't want a big old
hunk of cheese sitting
in the middle of this tomato.
So as long as you chop it
small, it's going to be great.
And it's going to mix
in really, really well.
So a little bit of-- just
a little bit of this.
We're going to add this on
top as well after this all
gets done.
Now the part where I
cheated, when I emptied out
the tomatoes-- again,
if you buy a store
bought tomato, that's
got so much core.
It's a commercial variety.
They're fine.
They're just a little
different than what
you're going to
grow in your garden,
but there's not
much there to use,
and I want to put
tomatoes into the mix.
So what I did was we
chopped up an heirloom,
so we took that beautiful--
this is an heirloom
called Gold Medal.
There's so many beautiful
heirloom varieties,
and I mean come on, that's
kind of amazing, right?
So to get the most
out of this thing,
why would I want an
industrial strength tomato
with not much taste, when I
got this going on in the spring
or in the late spring
and in the summer?
So I'm going to
take this, and I'm
going to use about a handful.
How's that for being exact?
And if it's me,
I'm using more just
because I want-- just
I want more of that,
and this is the base.
This is a beautiful
base of what's going on,
so you're going to put this in
here, and mix it up slightly,
and make a complete mess.
And this is where your
salad dressing comes in.
So claim all of
that off the sides
of the mortar and the pestle,
and mix that puppy dog in there
just so.
And like I said, you make this
little mound of paste in there,
and it sure doesn't look
like a lot of dressing,
but it goes a long way.
So I tend to like a lot
of dressing on salads.
Again, your call.
You can do whatever.
You just want it glossy.
You just want it glossy,
and this is so easy.
You can do it with your fingers.
You can make it, you know.
Have fun in the kitchen.
Play, get messy, and this
is the base of the salad.
Now it's really great
in these tomatoes
when it's cooked because
the arugula will cook down
a little bit, and it'll soften.
And that's what we want.
That's what we want
to have happen.
Dynamite salad.
Forgetting everything else, this
is a really dynamite little mix
for anything.
A little side, a little
anywhere you want to do that.
So can you see how
that's just glistening?
It's just barely there.
So it's not really wet,
and we're ready to go.
And this is where we go back
to our initial cut tomato.
Very simple.
Guess what happens next?
You take all that
beautiful mixture,
you stuff it in
there, all right?
Some will come out more
beautiful than others,
and that's all right.
And in the end, you guys,
what we'll generally
do when you plate
this or whatever,
you can put it in-- what's
really a really cool way
to do this is in a
mound of brown rice,
or like some wild
rice, or something.
We just put it in there
and set these puppies up so
that they don't fall over.
If you're using some varieties,
you can use some varieties
and even cut them
on end, so that you
have a flatter profile.
Where'd that other one go?
And you're good to go.
So this is going to go.
Again, if I was being a
little bit more spare here,
we could get these through
probably six to eight tomatoes.
So that's your pre-done
tomato, and you
can-- sometimes we'll add
a little bit more goat
cheese on the top here.
I'm going to wait till the
end to do that today, just
so it doesn't totally
melt all over everything.
And it'll look a little
puffy and fun and all of that
up on top of everything.
Turn the oven down
to about 350, so you
don't scorch these, which
isn't that much difference,
but it does make a
difference in the end.
And you only want these
in for just a few minutes.
If you put them in when
the tomatoes are warm,
you can really do
just a couple minutes,
and you're pretty good.
You want to keep a watch.
You want to keep an
eye on it and make sure
that the arugula should
be all wet, right?
It should be all-- sort of
have the olive oil all over it.
It shouldn't be
scorching, but you
don't want it to look
like yesterday's news.
So you want it
softening just a bit,
and then you're then you're
kind of raring to go.
You're raring to go.
While that's in there,
anybody got any questions
about tomatoes in
general, growing them?
Who's got them in the garden?
I know a lot of you do.
What are you thinking?
What can I help you with?
You guys, at this
point in the season,
you know, we're at midpoint
in the tomato season now.
There's lots of things, funny
looking things on leaves
and, you know, all over
the place that, you know,
that are there.
Do you have a curly top
question over there?
JENNA TAYLOR: So what's the
well, what's the question?
AUDIENCE: How long--
SCOTT DAIGRE: How long will
tomatoes last in the garden?
What a great, great question.
Thank you, Eva.
Tomatoes last in
the garden as long
as you plan for them to last.
And that's the bottom line.
There's a strategy involved
with growing tomatoes.
Did you ever develop one of
those when you-- come on.
You guys know about strategies.
You know about this.
Well, there's a strategy
in the tomato garden too.
If you want a long season,
you start right at the cusp,
right at the beginning of the
first available time, right?
When the temps, when the
nighttime temp-- and this is
a foul one, because our
nighttime temperatures,
above 55 degrees is
what we should be doing,
but that never really happens
until way late in the season.
But when your
daytime temperatures
are remarkable enough, high
enough so that it makes sense,
for most of you guys,
that would be when, Eva?
You probably plant the-- early
April, early to mid April?
Well, if you're me in
southern California,
we can be in March
1, and it really
depends on where you live.
So you pay attention to that.
Plant at the cusp of the season.
Then wait two
weeks, plant again,
so don't plant all
your tomatoes at once.
Plant three.
Leave a little space.
Plant three two weeks later.
Plant three three weeks later,
and plant one another couple
of month-- a month after that.
That way you've got a staggered
situation that will help you
because you don't
have all your tomatoes
come in at once, right?
That's a good thing, but
those later tomatoes,
because they generally will
start to grow and flower
in the highest
heat of the season,
probably won't
produce much then.
They'll relax, but
they'll be really strong.
As the other ones
are doing this,
they'll be really strong
as fall temps are cooling
and they'll come back up and
shoot flower and fruit for you
again.
So that's a really
good question.
It's all about what
the gardener decides.
You can decide to have a
really quick short season,
or you can have-- decide to have
a really great, long season,
and all your neighbors
will be jealous.
Why would one tomato get
something that the other one
doesn't?
Well, why is one of
us cold right now
and the other one's really warm?
I mean, that's kind
of what it gets to.
You look down a row of tomatoes.
In our test fields, Tomatomania!
test fields are full of
things that we can't really
figure out, because you
got a row of 25 tomatoes,
and two are doing fine.
The next two are doing OK.
The next one died.
Then that's how it happens.
It's kind of an amazing thing.
I was telling this story today.
That's one thing that sort
of awful pesticides fixed,
you know?
You killed everything, and
so everything does well.
Well, we don't love
that so much anymore,
and it is what happens.
Even the same varieties.
We test grow the same
varieties down a row.
You see the same
things happening.
JENNA TAYLOR: Like
natural selection
in the tomato community?
SCOTT DAIGRE: Kind of that, and
we were talking this morning.
Where did the seed come from?
How is it planted?
What's going on in that
soil versus that soil,
we never know.
Back to these real
quickly, guys.
That is a finished product.
Now, you see how
light that tomato is?
That's also-- how kind
of orangey it got?
That's also a product of
what kind of a tomato it is.
That actually got scorched
a little bit much.
I was chatting too much.
But look, this is
a beautiful thing
that you can use for,
again, just a little side,
a little appetizer,
or a big appetizer,
if you chose a big-- you know?
If you choose this.
Imagine that version.
That version of that
would be pretty great.
And in this one,
you could actually
scoop it out and use
the inside because it's
so delicious and nice
and soft, because it's
a big, beautiful heirloom.
And this is probably
one of the Pink Germans.
I'm not sure.
This one wasn't labeled,
but probably one of the Pink
German, German Queen.
There's a host of
beautiful German heirlooms
and from all over, or
heirlooms from all over Europe,
that kind of run
in this category.
And they're stupendous
and tasty and amazing.
Yes?
Heirlooms came into vogue
in the last 10 years.
What's so funny is
that my Tomatomania!
team and I sat down in
2001, after 10 years
of doing this event, and
we said, is heirloom over?
You know, are
heirlooms just done?
And I guess we didn't have to
worry about that, because it's
only gotten bigger.
Do you know the difference
between heirlooms and hybrids?
It's all about the seed.
An heirloom is true from seed.
If I grow this and it's a
German Queen, an heirloom,
if I grow it this year,
and I save seed correctly,
and I keep that seed
healthy and dry,
I can grow-- I can plant
it out next season.
I get the same tomato.
That's not true of your
hybrids that we have today.
For no other reason than
the seed is not stable.
A hybrid, like a
Sungold, the world's
most famous and favorite
tomato, little orange cherry,
which you've all had.
Beautiful, but if
you save that seed,
you've got a 33% shot of
getting Sungold next year,
which for some people isn't
bad, but hey, why don't you
buy the real seed?
And then it's
planned obsolescence,
is what a hybrid is.
That's what it is, and
that's the only difference.
You could stabilize that seed
over seven to nine generations,
and then you effectively
have an heirloom,
because it will
be true from seed.
That's the difference, and
heirlooms tell us a story.
We love them because they're
big and beautiful and not
so perfect, like a
lot of us, right?
And they do.
They have a lot of lore and a
little bit more story to them,
and we like that.
That's not to say that
hybrids aren't, you know?
We love our hybrids.
Hybrids are made to be strong,
productive, disease resistant,
you know?
Find something wrong
in that category.
There isn't anything.
They're terrific, so we
like to embrace all that,
and especially if
you're a new gardener.
If you're a new
gardener, grow hybrids.
Become successful.
That's really what we want at my
event more than anything else.
We want you to be successful.
So just start with hybrids
and learn how to do it.
Get it right, and then try the
crazy ones, just, you know--
and if you have a crazy big
yard, try as much you want.
That's good.
Yes?
JENNA TAYLOR: How do
you propagate those?
SCOTT DAIGRE:How
do you propagate?
You can do it--
you can obviously
propagate tomatoes seed to seed,
if you're propagating this way,
but you can use-- you can cut
and root a stem of a tomato
very easily.
The stems are hairy, and all
of those hairs turn into roots
very, very quickly.
So if you'll take
a seven to eight--
you can even let one
of the little side
branches grow that grows in the
middle of the leaf and the stem
right there.
Wait till it gets
7, 8 inches long.
Put it in a glass of water
for four or five days, a week,
whatever.
Pop it out into the garden.
Cover it for a while and
keep it a little moist.
It'll look like-- it'll bitch
and moan and be all, you know,
look bad for a while, and it's
going to come back just fine
and be great.
So they're tough,
and that's actually--
talk about a long season.
You find a favorite tomato,
take cuttings of that plant
and put it in your garden
down underneath the mother.
You'll have it as
long as you have it,
as long as the weather allows,
and that's a beautiful way
to lengthen your season and
be a real gardener too, right?
Because that's a real
gardener thing there.
All right, anybody else?
You mean if you're
cooking with it?
Oh, gosh.
Well, you can totally use it.
Look, you can use
it in this recipe.
I'm just being funny, because
I used these today because I
like the way they keep their
shape, and they're firmer.
You can totally do it with this.
You could absolutely
do it with that.
You just have to be careful
not to-- it's a little funny.
You're going to get
into those loaves,
and it's kind of harder
to clean out, number one.
And you just have to leave
a little bit more skin,
a little bit more
width on the outside,
and you'll do just fine.
But you do have to watch
it, because they're
softer from the get go.
And they'll shrink and just
kind of fall apart on you.
So that's the only
thing, because I
want you to use
every piece of it,
but I didn't mean to-- you know,
I just wanted to caution you,
and I-- again, I think
those look kind of cool.
Given their little red, nice,
little round little boats,
but you can always
do it with this.
You can always do it with that.
Other questions, yes?
Oh, green tomatoes.
How do you use green tomatoes?
They're great in a salsa.
They're really, really
good in a salsa.
Or a salsa-- you know, we've
done all sorts of things
with that, mixed with tomatillos
and doing a whole green theme.
I've heard of people making
green tomato ketchup.
Right?
Cook it down, soften it up.
It doesn't taste like
red tomato ketchup,
I'll tell you that much.
But it's interesting,
and it's different.
And so I think the salsas are
probably your best way to go.
They're much like
this, only green.
I mean the store bought
varieties, right?
So you have to probably cook
them a little bit longer,
all of that, but they're--
AUDIENCE: Would they
taste good like this?
SCOTT DAIGRE:I don't
know that they would.
I mean frankly, it's going to
be a little bit, a vessel that's
unfinished.
So it might, you know--
it's going to have a taste.
Just overdo these
elements a little bit.
A little bit more salt,
a little bit more pepper.
A little bit more zing.
You can-- you'll
be fine with it.
Yeah, I think it would be great.
Is it OK to put cooked
spinach and tomatoes together?
I do it all the time.
I'm still standing here.
No, I think it's fine, and
again, you're not cooking.
You're really
warming here, right?
All you're doing
is kind of having
it sink down into that
boat a little bit,
and so that you get
this finished product.
That's really what you're doing.
And I didn't put goat
cheese on top of there.
Doggone.
I was going to do that
while it was warm,
so that's the finishing
touch on these.
I totally forgot that.
And there you are, but I think
you'll be fine with that.
And like kale, you know,
kale's a little tougher.
You might have to cook
that little longer, warm
it a little longer,
and you'll be fine.
OK, anybody else?
Other questions?
Yes, sir?
How do you eat
tomatoes in winter?
You don't, you know?
I think with lots of
seasoning, lots of seasoning,
or you know, put
them in the freezer.
Hey, hello.
JENNA TAYLOR: Or can?
SCOTT DAIGRE:Do
you have tomatoes?
Tomatoes?
Huh?
JENNA TAYLOR: Or can them?
SCOTT DAIGRE: Can them.
You can totally can them.
You can freeze a
tomato just like that.
Open your freezer, or
open your freezer door.
Put it in, and put it
in one of those bins,
and close the freezer door.
Done, and I'm serious.
As you thaw this baby,
the skin sorta fall off.
Boom.
That's one icky job done, right?
You don't have to blanch and
do all that mess anymore.
Seriously, stack them in
one corner of your freezer,
and they're ready for
you when you want.
Now, you can't make
a salad out of that
when you thaw it out, right?
But you can make a
really nice sauce.
It locks in the flavors, right?
And it works exceedingly well.
And I don't know if you've
ever heard of tomato water.
Tomato water for cocktails.
Tomato water for some recipes.
It's basically the clear
liquid that-- the gel and some
of the liquid that's inside
of there that drains out
if we were to cut it.
If you use tomato water, and
you have a frozen tomato,
it's the most glorious thing.
You pop that in a bowl
or something frozen,
and you make a few
slits around the bottom.
The tomato melts, and you get
this beautiful, clear, perfect
unsullied tomato
water that's killer.
So if you use that,
that's a great way
to use a frozen tomato.
But yeah, seriously, just throw
it in the freezer, you're done,
and you will have
it all season long.
Just not that great when
you're going to go sort of bite
into and enjoy the way we
do in the summer, right?
Yes.
Remove the seeds when
you're cooking a tomato?
Some people have some people
have trouble with that,
with seeds in their diet, right?
Because of gastro issues.
So you can.
I don't.
I never received-- I never
remove the seeds in anything.
I really don't, and
frankly, I like the skins.
There's a lot of nutrition
right under the skin.
So when you remove the
skin of the tomato,
you're kind of removing a good
bit of the-- a good bit of what
you really want in there anyway.
So I think it's a really-- you
know, I'll puree something.
If the skins bother me,
I'll just puree it all,
and that way you get
all that good stuff.
And I hope you enjoy that.
And so I think it's good there.
I don't bother,
but some people do.
Some people, you know, people
who know a lot more than me
about taste say
that the seed, that
umame that we get in
a tomato is critical.
It's critical to eat the
seed and to get that whole,
you know, the whole
realm of flavor.
So there you go.
Yeah, I don't leave them out.
It's mostly because
I'm kind of lazy,
and I don't want to do that all.
But when I get umame on the
top of it, I'm pretty good.
All right?
Anybody else?
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: With the
seeds, how do you
harvest it for the next season?
SCOTT DAIGRE: How do you
harden for next season?
How do you save a seed?
Pretty simple stuff.
You take a tomato.
And you do this, right?
And you get some seeds,
or you get seeds and pulp
in a small, clear
cup or bowl, right?
And you get about
half an inch and you
let that sit outside
for three days.
And it begins to ferment.
You want to ferment the seed,
because the fermentation
process causes all that
gel, which is an inhibitor,
to go away.
So now the seed is bare.
After three or four days,
it's sitting in that gook
for three or four days.
You put it under the
faucet and run it around.
The good seed will
sink to the bottom,
and the bad seed floats.
Pour that off with the
pulp, and keep doing
that until you have only seed.
Pour it off, dry it out, put
it in an envelope, or some kind
of a canister with a Kleenex
or some sort of a desiccant
that will take up any excess
moisture, or extra moisture,
and you're off to the races.
Store it in a cool place.
You can have them
for 10, 15 years.
They could be viable
Eva?
Where else should you
find heirloom seeds?
Well, you could Google
it, probably, you know?
I think you could find--
if you find heirlooms,
you could find heirloom
seeds everywhere, but yeah.
Thanks to Google, we
can find heirloom seeds
all over the place, from
the tiniest of suppliers,
who are doing two varieties
that they're really,
you know, enamored of,
to Tomato Fest that's
out of Monterey, Carmel, right?
And they have 600 varieties.
600 varieties of seeds.
Lots of information for
you, lots of good things
that you can learn,
so all over the place.
Tomato Fest, Seed
Savers, there's
a slew of wonderful people
who are working hard
to keep all these great
heirlooms alive, right?
And to keep them
in the marketplace
and keep them viable, and
we're thankful for that.
So yes, plenty of places to
get good seed, all right?
Plant food or
fertilizer for tomatoes.
Mix it up.
Use a good soil
amendment so that you're
feeding with the medium
you plant in, right?
Use a compost tea.
Use a granular that's balanced.
You want it balanced.
You want the numbers
on that fertilizer bag
to be more similar than
they are disparate, right?
And change it up.
Do something different so
that you're giving them
a wide spectrum of
things, or if you have to,
just use that one balanced
product that somebody's
already mixed for you.
So it matters not.
It matters not.
The key thing about
fertilizer is to use it.
It doesn't matter
what kind it is.
A lot of us buy fertilizer
and put in the shed,
and there it stays
all season long.
And that's the end
of that, right?
Why didn't my tomatoes work?
Buy it and use it.
That's how it
works, and you guys,
if you've never
done foliar feeding,
foliar feeding is a terrific
way to feed tomatoes.
It basically is any
solution, whether it's fish
emulsion-- it's all
nitrogen, so careful-- fish
emulsion, compost
tea, any of that,
that you can actually
spray on the leaves
as well as put in,
soak the roots with,
and it takes it up both ways.
And the tomato is hugely
efficient at using
fertilizer that's been
put on the leaves, OK?
JENNA TAYLOR: The Topsy
Turvy hanging upside down
tomato plants?
SCOTT DAIGRE: Oh,
the Topsy Turvy?
Ooh, the Topsy Turvy.
Do you know this one?
The little tiny--
here's my problem.
The little tiny container
that you're going
to grow a tomato in, right?
I get 50% of people
saying thumbs up,
and 50% of people
saying thumbs down.
If you're a really good
gardener, and very on
top of it, and you have a
sprinkler system that you
could drip it on, yeah.
They could be
successful, and you
don't put them in all day
sun, for goodness sakes,
because it's a tiny container.
It can work.
Choose the right tomato
and be on top of it.
You'll be just fine.
Thank you, everybody.
I hope you enjoyed that.
It's been such a
blast being here,
and being on-- seeing a little
bit of what-- where you live,
and that's, that's
really awesome.
Keep up the good work in
the garden, and you know,
keep-- but I feel like I
should say thank you for the,
you know-- being at the
center of the universe
is kind of cool,
and I like that.
So it's been a pleasure.
JENNA TAYLOR: And thank
you for joining us.
SCOTT DAIGRE: It's
been a pleasure.
Thank you, Jenna.
Thanks everybody.
[APPLAUSE]